public schools in our northern urban centers
are no longer instruments of upward mobility
for minority and Laura status children they are
for the most part institutions for breeding the
spear frustration and sowing the seeds of
self-destruction and social instability I
am Negro I am bad I am poor white trash I am
bad I don't know what that teacher says I am
bad my teacher puts a paper on my desk I
don't know what to do I do nothing I am
bad bad boys put their heads on their desk I
am very bad Who am I I run I shout I hit that
kid next to me I am Negro and poor white trash
I don't know nothing I don't listen I am lazy
I don't sit still I mark on my papers I hip
kids I know who I am I'm the baddest kid in
the room everybody knows it I'm so bad the day the
teacher smiled at me hello I like that red shirt I
don't say nothing dumb funny mark said my name I
believe I can make one of them funny mine I made
one on the board I feel good my teacher says my
that is good some of these days you can write all
your name you're a smart boy I'm glad you're
in my room but she likes me I'm a boy [Music]
see you don't need those papers you know them
now so when you come in and we're going to do
numbers you don't need to read them for me
anymore because you know them and I look
for teachers who teach rather than the color
of the skin the way the teacher interacts on
a humane way with the learner also builds
confidence on the part of a learner in the
teacher the teacher also must relate in a way
with the learner that she expects him to learn
she expects him to achieve with these elements
operative a learner learns to have confidence
in himself confidence in the teacher and knows
that in the learning situation he can perform
and he is expected to perform then the Goblin
ran off into the bushes clutching his pencil
and leaving Annabelle sitting there in her
underwear he defend himself by scratching or
biting you see but as long as you do not hurt
him he's not he's not going to scratch or bite
you now I wanted to tell you something about
this animal - now let me show you him Cedric
would you like to hold rascal Cedric is a little
apprehensive about this guy now let's take the
skunk here if you notice his claws here they are
adapted for digging I feel that the schools are
doing the best they can and you have to have
help on the parents too because you just can't
send your child to school and tell the teacher
to teach him you have to help her along [Music]